this is bartela it's a christian village
it was evacuated two years ago
and those who got left behind in all
probability were murdered it's taken
four days of ferocious fighting in an
area in which there were no
civilians to get in the way to liberate
the town
so these are newly armored vehicles with
brand new
armored windows they look very very
different once they've seen a bit of
combat
contrast that with the deadly accuracy
of so many of these islamic state
fighters
who focus their fire on these armored
windows trying to punch through
the glass and look at the effects here
that is round after round after round
onto this armored glass
not yet getting through but ultimately
they will and this
is why these fighters are also so
dangerous
they're very very good shots
this is a classic example of a fighting
position used by the so-called islamic
state this is a
bunker on the edge of a warehouse it
leads to
a tunnel complex there are wires
everywhere some for communication
others to detonate improvised explosive
devices
this enormous hull can't even see the
bottom of it
is part of the beginning of a tunnel
complex
they have tunnels almost completely
impervious to air strikes unless they're
using the most advanced sort of bunker
buster
improvised engineering that is making
the islamic state
so difficult to deal with in this battle
and why this town has taken so long
people pop up out of these hulls
and attack from the rear
this is the syriac orthodox church it's
been burnt
it's obviously been trashed and it's
become
nothing more really than a dovecot
deliberate
of course we should expect this but
deliberate desecration of holy sites
by the so-called islamic state but by
their standards this is pretty minor
elsewhere in territory under their
control
they've actually blown up particularly
ancient buildings
especially in this province some of the
greatest archaeological gems
have been turned to rubbish and dust
these are christian graves tombs every
one of which has been broken open
and the iraqi forces here say everything
inside them has been stolen